هذا كما أقول أول آلة نقل عن بعد
كانت الفكرة الرئيسية في البداية هي
الترحيب بأختي التي لديها
إعاقات للسفر دون حركة جسدية
لذلك كانت هذه الفكرة الرئيسية في
البداية وبعد أربع سنوات من
العمل الفني أه صنعنا هذا المنتج أه
وهي أول آلة نقل عن بعد حقيقية ،
لذا فأنت داخل الكبسولة في
كل مكان حولك محاطًا
بشاشة ويمكننا عرض أي محتوى 360
لديك أو
تريده وهذا هو السبب في أننا نقول إنها آلة نقل عن بعد
لأنه يمكننا الحصول على كاميرا
في أي وقت على الأرض  وهي ترسل
الصور مباشرة داخل الكبسولة ،
لذلك قمنا في الواقع بإنشاء
15 مقطع فيديو ومحتويات لعرض
ما يمكن أن يفعله المنتج
من
زيارات
قصر فرساي أو إعادة التدوير في فرنسا
من زيارات المناظر الطبيعية الشهيرة في
الطائرات بدون طيار في فرنسا قمنا أيضًا بتطوير
أفلام كرتونية حول تعليم التلوث
وما إلى ذلك ، لذا فقد صنعنا الكثير من مقاطع
الفيديو متزامنة مع
موضوعات جناح السياج
أه نستهدف الآن اثنين ب  الأسواق المستهدفة ig
الأول هو صناعة الترفيه
مثل حدائق ألعاب الفيديو وما إلى ذلك
لأن لدينا منتجًا صغيرًا
يمكنه استيعاب ما يصل إلى أربعة أشخاص والإبلاغ
عنهم أينما يريدون ، لذا
فهي حقًا الروح الحقيقية لهذا
المنتج  روح صناعة الترفيه
أساسًا
هدفنا الثاني هو
صناعات الشركات الكبرى مثل
حالات الاستخدام وأغراض النقل الفضائي
لإجراء بعض عمليات الصيانة عن بُعد على الطائرات
أو المرافق
للذهاب إلى أماكن لا يمكننا الذهاب إليها جسديًا
لأنه إذا لم تتمكن من الوصول إليها  أو
أيًا كان ما يمكننا استخدامه أيضًا في
صناعة السفر ، مثل يمكنك زيارة
الأماكن عن بُعد ، يمكنك زيارة المنزل
الذي استأجرته والأماكن التي
ستزورها خلال عطلتك القادمة وما إلى
ذلك نظرًا لأنها آلة انتقال عن بعد ،
يمكننا الانتقال الفوري أينما تريد  للذهاب
كان لدينا 1500 شخص يذهبون ويقولون
إنها تجربة غامرة حقًا
أولاً وثانيًا نشعر حقًا
أننا انتقلنا إلى هناك
[موسيقى]